hey Vsauce Michael here but when is here
and how much does it weigh that's
supposed to be me huh imitation is a
form of flattery an honor but what is
the greatest honor possible let's begin
our journey by looking at challenges and
achievements worthy of honor first the
physical ones being the fastest person
to run a marathon 26.2 miles is great
but why stop there
the Ironman Triathlon involves swimming
2.4 miles racing on a bicycle 112 miles
and then running an entire marathon
record holder Craig Alexander did it all
in 8 hours 3 minutes and 56 seconds
beyond that things begin to get mental
the self transcendence race held every
summer in New York is the longest
certified foot race on the planet it's
not 26 miles long it's 3100 and instead
of running thousands of miles across the
very landscape of the US competitors
merely run around the same city block in
Queens five thousand six hundred and
forty nine times you have 52 days to
complete the race and doing so can wear
out as many as 12 pairs of shoes the
fastest time for completing the race
goes to Wolfgang shirk who finished in
just 41 days averaging 75 miles of
running every day in the realm of
entertainment there are very clear
physical rewards statuettes like the
Emmy the Grammy the Oscar and the Tony
winning at least one of each is called
an e got so far 11 humans have won all
four awards in competitive categories
Marvin Hamlisch and Richard Rodgers also
each won a Pulitzer Prize Lynn Redgrave
is the only person to have ever been
nominated for all four Awards
without winning a single one some people
have one surprising combinations of
awards Steve Tisch as chairman and
executive vice president of the New York
Giants and producer of films like
Forrest Gump American History X and
snatch is the only person in history to
have won both a Super Bowl ring and an
Oscar and throughout all of human
history only one person has won an Oscar
and a Nobel Prize George Bernard Shaw
those are neat facts but let's define
honor there are two guys we should go to
the first is Noah Webster who's American
Dictionary is the reason Americans spell
it honor the second guy is Samuel
Johnson who's English Dictionary is the
reason people across the Atlantic where
I usually am spell it honor
Johnson differentiated two types of
honor that are relevant to the question
in this video's title the first is what
he calls nobility of soul magnanimity
and the scorn of meanness this is honor
derived not from achievement at
something competitive but rather from
perceived virtuous conduct and personal
integrity but what counts as a virtue
well one of my favorite attempts to
catalog human virtues was done by
Christopher Peterson and Martin Seligman
frustrated by a persistent focus on
mental illness they devised a guide to
mental wellness their catalog contains
24 virtues and strengths shared across
nearly every human culture they attached
historical figures believed to personify
each trait and their list of 24 included
fairness humility hope humor
appreciation of beauty and the love of
learning
using their list as a scorecard for
virtue points to determine the most
honorable person is impossible but that
hasn't stopped people from discussing
the greatest honor in terms of virtue
Richard Nixon did some things that
people might consider dishonorable but
his perspective is illuminating and his
first inaugural address he said the
greatest honor history can bestow is the
title of peacemaker peacemaker but who
has the authority to judge virtue
hopefully not individuals
Richard Wiseman's brilliant core ecology
discusses a survey conducted in 1997 by
US News & World Report which asked
people who they thought was somewhat
likely to go to heaven as a marker of
perceived virtuous conduct and personal
integrity it's really illuminating 52%
thought that Bill Clinton would 60%
thought Princess Diana would and a full
79 percent said that they thought Mother
Teresa would go to heaven but she was
only second place 87 percent of
respondents agreed that someone else was
likely to go to heaven who did they
think that was themselves the greatest
honor a country bestows upon those who
have defended it fought for it often
carries the most awe-inspiring stories
the greatest military honor in the
United Kingdom is the Victoria Cross in
the United States
it's the medal of honor given for
conspicuous gallantry and intrepidity at
the risk of life above and beyond the
call of duty many of its recipients are
honored posthumously they are people who
acted instantly and without regard for
their own safety they've walked into
enemy fire losing their lives to
communicate life-saving messages they
have fallen on grenades to absorb the
impact with their bodies so that others
around them
wouldn't have to Samuel Johnson's second
definition of honor focuses not so much
on honor that comes from being ethically
excellent but instead on honor that
comes from power from being royal or
famous global surveys have shown that
many corporate logos like the golden
arches are more famous than any
celebrity or other symbol so technically
speaking the greatest honor as far as
becoming famous and globally known might
simply be to become a fast-food mascot
not all honorable people get honored how
does a grand recognized public act made
possible by being in the right place at
the right time with the right
opportunities compared to the honor of
merely being the best person you can be
a good citizen a mother a father an
otherwise unrecognized person who is
nonetheless an amazing hero to a few
your family your friends that one person
who really needed you is recognition
merely an accident of luck a snowball
effect an accumulation of advantage
people who stand out when they are young
are often given access to more
opportunities which then leads to and
entitles them to more opportunities
later on accumulating overtime like snow
on a snowball that eventually becomes an
entire Boulder of snow only the original
snowball of which was the original
person historians have pointed this
phenomenon out to the accumulation of
advantage when criticizing the great man
theory of history the idea that human
history can be taught or understood as a
timeline of a few important honored
individuals Philip Zimbardo
the researcher behind the infamous
Stanford Prison study has shown that the
wrong situation can bring out evil in
almost anybody he's stressed in his
recent TED talk but not all of us will
encounter
just the right opportunities to become
the next Gandhi or Neil Armstrong but
what we can do is live our lives with
what Zimbardo calls and heroic
imagination as a hero in waiting who
thinks so Co centrically not egocentric
Lee he says most heroes are everyday
people who emerge as heroes in
particular situations so a fair argument
can be made that simply knowing you did
the right thing when presented with a
situation involving Peterson and
Seligman's virtues and strengths is the
greatest honor possible the most
honorable life now whether or not that
honorable behavior is recognized
while Cato the Elder questioned the
value imparted by physical Awards by
simply saying after I'm dead I'd rather
have people ask why I have no monument
then why I have one it's an honor to
talk to you guys every week so as always
thanks for watching
you
[Music]